So for the final question of homework 2
your goal is to define a procedure called print_multiplication_table
and it takes as input a single positive whole number
and it prints out a multiplication table showing all the whole number multiplications
up to and including the input number.
So here is an example.
If the input is the number 2 what you should print out is:
I hope I got all those right without using the interpreter.
To be correct, you must print them out in the same order as we're showing here.
There will be a longer example in the coments to make sure the order is clear.
They should match exactly this format as well.
This is a pretty hard question, so it's worth a gold star.
Actually, I'm going to make it worth two gold stars.
As a hint, one of the things you need to think about to do this question
is something that we haven't seen before,
but you've seen it for ifs.
We saw in the lecture to define biggest that we used one if inside another if.
To solve this you're going to have to think about using a while inside another while.